Have you ever wanted to know everything there
is to know about the people who watch your
YouTube show?
Like, how many of them are educators, or learners,
whether they're just watching for fun, or
just when they're studying, how many teachers
are playing your videos in schools?
It's probably just me.
Well, I don't care!
Welcome to Crash Course Surveys, a one-episode
series here on Crash Course, where I implore
you to please fill out a survey so that we
can know more about our audience, how you
use Crash Course, and how we can make better
content for you.
Your answers to these questions are going
to help us refine our mission, maybe help
us raise money to make more great videos,
or even develop broader resources for learners
and educators!
Expand our reach and just generally make the
world a better place!
So please, please please, help us out!
There are two surveys in the description below,
one is for educators, so people who are using
Crash Course to help other people learn, regardless
of the circumstances, and one is for learners
- people who are using Crash Course to help
themselves learn.
Again, regardless of the circumstances.
If you fall under both groups, fill out both
surveys!
Thank you so much for your dedication to and
interest in Crash Course.
We're very proud of what we've built here,
and want very much to make it even better.